I'm rating every devil fruit in one
piece to figure out which one's the best
today we're looking at the guragura Nomi
the Tremor Tremor fruit which gives you
the ability to produce literal
earthquakes this style fruit is owned by
not one but two of the strongest pirates
in the world in terms of strength is
literally the most destructive fruit in
all of One Piece it's so powerful that
it's said to have the power to destroy
the entire world perfect score 25 points
on the other hand this fruit doesn't
give its user any sort of defense or
increase durability no points here for
special abilities the Tremor fruit can
destroy normal buildings and people
alike but can also be used to summon
gigantic tsunami waves that can drown
entire islands and drown other devil
fruit users as well 20 points this devil
fruit does have some pretty devastating
drawbacks any large-scale attack with an
earthquake or tsunami will not only hurt
your enemies also your allies making it
really hard to use in big battles for
that I'll deduct 15 points which brings
its final score to a whooping 35 points